sheamus i'll pull you in because you got
a question here about
uh making room for progress so how you
doing man you're back
hey how's it going going good yeah i
said the
super chat earlier um thank you i'm here
in the car in honor of
uh the first video of yours i saw you
driving around
very good sir yeah uh well uh
uh congratulations real quick i want to
throw a top out there i'll give you two
examples and see what y'all's taking any
more uh ideas is
it's clearing out your life to make room
for progress
one example is uh i had a real
issue with society saying i should be
friends with my exes and i noticed that
they called me a lot to be the emotional
tampon and i finally told them look
lose my number done go away uh second
thing was uh cleared out a whole bunch
of the stuff from the garage
got the the weight set set up i'll be
hosting that on my channel for part of
the progress
but i wanted to give those examples kind
of open the floor and
see what are some good ideas for you
from you guys about
clearing out your life from things that
get in the way of progress and opening
up
room for future progress all right so
i'll give you one of the best sound
bites you can use with x's um this works
especially well with ex-wives
uh ex-girlfriends you might have lived
with had an ltr with and they're
looking to use you as an emotional
tampon or just
ask you for help or assistance with
something the wi-fi router's not working
what do i do seamus
i don't work for you anymore
that works for everything i don't work
for you anymore
because a lot of the times they they
seem to have these expectations that
yeah that you're that useful idiot you
know that's that's that's always going
to be available to them to solve their
problems because
let's be honest like women have been
sold this lie their entire life that
they're
that they're extremely valuable and men
should bend the knee to them and all
this sort of stuff and i
you know i continue to teach you guys to
set some boundaries and be firm with
them and
why you should and how it serves you
better and it actually serves your
relationships better too but just simply
saying i don't work for you anymore
those words alone those those those few
words solve
a lot of problems and it sends a very
very clear message to them
yeah and not a single one of them that i
told to lose my number
none of them reacted well i got hung up
on by one of them the other one started
yelling
i hung up on her uh the other one just
immediately started crying and i'm like
no i'm done
bye yeah i don't work for you anymore
because
they seem to think for some reason that
you're still [ __ ] available to them
to fix their problems or to be their
emotional tampons
just tell them oh yeah i don't work
there anymore
i am i am no longer your [ __ ]
employee man
oh yeah yeah and then the second part
that was
oh yeah second part
oh the second part now is just an
example of like things that i've done
uh recently i've seen if y'all had any
more ideas like um
by the end of the month i'm going to
quit smoking made room in the garage
for uh the weight set i've got a bench
set and a squat rack
um i'm not built for lifting
um redoing the all of that kind of stuff
um just making room
in your life in general for progress
yeah dude well a lot of it is rich talks
about all the time too i've said it you
talked about it too
in other other ways i'm just managing
your [ __ ] right
i mean just stop giving a [ __ ] about
these things dude like i just don't have
time to give a [ __ ]
about [ __ ] like i don't and so like
if i'm
it when guys are wondering or you know
guys that are not you necessarily but
guys listening
they're like man how do i you know how
do i you know
get rid of some of these toxic forces in
my life or these friends or these
ex-girlfriends or whatever like i need
to
their ankle their ankle weights how do i
get rid of them stop giving a [ __ ]
i mean if your focus another part is is
do more [ __ ]
for what you need to be doing if you're
doing so much [ __ ] every day
to get you ahead with what you need to
be doing you just don't have time
and that becomes what's important and
then you're not even calling that
ex back that texted you or whatever you
just don't have time for that [ __ ]
you know what i mean it's just you're
just moving on and people will deal with
it
you know they'll deal with it and
they'll understand it 100
cool or they won't and that's not my
problem
i learned that from you guys not my
problem another very good i love being
able to say that these days
don't make your problems my problems
yeah
huge thing right there that works with a
lot of different scenarios
girlfriends ex-girlfriends friends
doesn't matter family even right
it's like you know a lot of people seem
to think that their lack of
preparation on their part constitutes an
emergency on your part
right
i know what i know it might sound cold
and people are like oh rich you're still
stuck man you know
you know you're an [ __ ] no i just you
know that's just but you're not though
you're deciding it's the it's
yeah it's the weirdest thing it's i
always thought being an [ __ ] was a
bad thing i found the more
i enforce my boundaries and act like an
[ __ ] all of a sudden people that
never listened to what i had to say
they're suddenly respecting me now
correct yeah
well and i will say too i hope i help
people out all the time man
it's fine but the difference is i do it
on i do it without sacrificing myself to
do so and setting boundaries
and you know what happens when you set
boundaries and when you do help somebody
out they appreciate it
ten times more because they know that
you value yourself and they value what
you're doing
and you're taking time from that to help
them they appreciate it they don't
appreciate it they become entitled
when you are trying to make everyone
else's problems your problems and you're
not on your own purpose
then people become entitled and expect
you to you know to do more and
and that you didn't do enough you know
what i mean so
that's the thing you can help people you
just do it on your terms you know
100 all right brother
that sounds good guys thank you very
much uh be sure to
you know check out uh coffee medic and
let me know what you all think
coffee what coffee coffee medic
okay underscore medic yeah all right
it'll have a picture of my
coffee mug all right man thanks
you